[MUSIC PLAYING]
YUFENG GUO: Did you know that
you can convert a Keras model
to a TensorFlow estimator?
It'll give you a whole host
of options around distributed
training and scaling.
Stay tuned to find out how.
Welcome to "Cloud
AI Adventures,"
where we explore
the art, science,
and tools of machine learning.
My name is Yufeng Guo.
And on this episode,
we are going
to prepare a Keras model for
running at scale by converting
it to a TensorFlow estimator.
So we have a Keras model--
easy to define, clear to read,
and friendly to maintain.
But it doesn't do so good with
scaling up to larger datasets
or running across many machines.
Luckily, Keras and
TensorFlow have
some fantastic
interoperability features.
What we want to do is
convert our Keras model
to a TensorFlow estimator,
which comes with the distributed
training built in.
That's our ticket to solving
our scaling challenges.
Plus it makes it easy
to do model serving
once our training is complete.
The function that
we are interested in
is called model_to_estimator.
And I've taken the
notebook we started
with in the previous episode
and updated it with new code
to convert our Keras model
to a TensorFlow estimator.
We'll also take a look at
how to export your Keras
model as is once training
is complete, along
with the TensorFlow model.
Let's switch over now to
the Kaggle notebook and dive
into the code.
So here we are back
in our Kaggle kernel
with our Fashion MNIST dataset.
This code should look
eminently familiar.
We're going to load up
NumPy, pandas, TensorFlow,
and that plotlib.
And we're going to
pull in our dataset
with pandas, reading
those CSV files,
and take a peek at the
first couple of rows.
We can see that the first
column is our label column
and all our pixels
are all the rest
of the columns to the right.
I've got this handy
preprocessing function,
which takes our data
frame and pulls out
the values for the
features and the labels.
And then we can
save them directly
into the variables, like
train features, train labels,
test features, and test labels.
Then we'll go ahead and
do our one-hot encoding.
This is exactly the same as we
saw in our previous episode.
We're going to convert those
labels, which were numbers,
to labels that are arrays
of length 10 for our 10
different possible labels.
Then we'll run our train.
We've got our
training parameters
and we'll create
our Keras model.
This is exactly the same code
that we saw to create our Keras
model before.
And once we have that created,
we can run model.fit--
identical to what we saw
in the previous episode.
Once we have our model fit,
we can go ahead and test it.
And now, we get to the
interesting stuff--
our conversion.
How do we convert our Keras
model to TensorFlow estimator?
We'll use model_to_estimator.
This function takes a couple
of different arguments.
But in our case,
we're just going
to pass it the one
pointer to our model--
to the argument Keras model.
And that will convert
our Keras model
into a TensorFlow estimator.
Once we have our TensorFlow
estimator in hand,
we can do everything
we would normally
do with a TensorFlow estimator.
In this case, I've chosen
to go ahead and train it.
We should train our
estimator and see
what we can achieve in terms
of accuracy and performance.
So if we want to
do that, first we
need to think about how do we
architect our input function.
And the big question
there is for our features,
we need a label
for those features.
What do we call it?
When we're coming from Keras,
we don't really get to name it
ourselves.
We have to run
model.input_names.
And this is the input names
of the Keras model, not
the TensorFlow model.
Those names are copied over.
And so we can look
at our Keras model
and see that, in this case,
it's called dense_3_input.
And when we pull it out,
we'll use that variable input
name, which points
to dense_3_input,
as our key for our features.
And so once we have
that set up, we
can do pretty much
the same as what
we're used to seeing with
TensorFlow estimator training.
We'll have our feature columns.
In this case, I'm going to
rename our tf classifier
as just classifier.
And now, we can train.
And since we used the
correct input names,
we can do this
without any errors.
If you don't use the
right input names,
you will get errors, so be sure
to get that input name out.
Now, we can run
evaluate and set up
that evaluate_input function.
You'll notice that we'll need
to use that input name once
again here, so a really
good idea to save that off
to a variable.
Another thing to notice here is
that we used the one-hot labels
in the TensorFlow
training and evaluation,
just like we did in Keras.
Now when we ran this
model in pure TensorFlow
in the past with
Fashion MNIST, we
were able to use the
not-one-hot encoded labels.
We could just use the labels
that were 5, and 7, and 9.
In this case, because we took
the model directly from Keras
and moved it to
TensorFlow, that conversion
also resulted in
the model expecting
one-hot encoded labels.
And so you'll need to make
sure you use the same labels
as you did in Keras.
In practice, this ends up being
really convenient because you
can just use the same
variables in the same arrays
that you used before.
Now, we can see that the
evaluation is completed.
In this case, we got to 86%.
And in Keras, I think we
got something similar.
We can see here-- yeah, 85%.
The accuracies
will vary depending
on a number of different
factors ranging
from the random
initialization state, how
my computer is feeling on a
given day, things like that.
Now that we have our models
trained in both Keras
and TensorFlow, let's
take a brief look
at how we would export
these models out
into the file system.
Keras models are very
straightforward to export.
You just call model.save
and give it a name,
and it will export it
in the HDF5 format.
On the TensorFlow side,
exporting our model
requires the use of the
export_savedmodel function.
This function takes
two arguments.
One is a path to export it to.
And secondly, a serving
input receiver function,
which for short is often just
called a serving function.
TensorFlow has a
utility to help you
build that serving function.
And that takes, as an
argument, this mapping
of the input shape and type.
This helps the model know
what kind of inputs to expect.
So once we run our
export_savedmodel
on our TensorFlow model, we can
see where it was exported to.
And we can see that
TensorFlow exports models
as a file and a folder
called variables.
So for convenience, I also
like to zip it up or tar it
up so that it's
easy to download.
And then on the other
side, once you download it,
you can unzip it
with tar as well.
So that's kind of
what's involved
with taking a Keras model.
We've taken that, converted
it to a TensorFlow estimator,
and then exported that
TensorFlow estimator.
We've managed to do all
of this without actually
creating a TensorFlow
estimator from scratch.
We've gone all the way
from taking a Keras model,
training it, converting it
to a TensorFlow estimator,
training that, and then
exporting the two of them.
And we'll be able to
use those exported files
in future episodes to do
more interesting things.
Getting distributed training
using TensorFlow estimators
is an easy one-line adjustment
to your Keras model.
So now, you have the
best of both worlds--
easy to read Keras model
creation syntax along
with distributed training
via TensorFlow estimators.
Thanks for watching this episode
of "Cloud AI Adventures."
And if you enjoyed
it, please like it
and subscribe to get all
the latest episodes right
when they come out.
For now, remember
that all you need
to get distributed training
working with your Keras model
is to use model_to_estimator.